pâtes à la tomate et au basilic aujourd'hui
pâtes courtes et pourquoi l'autre soir je
tagliolini ou collé que peut-être oui
Je suis lilia la fille le vin là-bas
Je n'ai pas eu à faire le classique qui
Je ne fais la queue que la nuit tu sers
maintenir cet équilibre devient
de plus en plus difficile
c'est toi qui dois évaluer je ne sais pas
s'il faut le préparer
faire quelque chose de nouveau différent alors
au moins un de vos régimes un sur deux choisit
la fille obtient donc nous donnons
c'est vrai que ce n'est pas une rivière triste
premier plan d'énergie d'espoir c'est
vraiment contacter
parce que j'aime la maison que tu as